édition spéciale dans ce journal un
document tourné en 1942 amsterdam sous
l'occupation nazie
la vie d'un groupe de juifs réfugiés
dans un cabaret avant d'être déportés un
film qui ressemble au journal d'anne
frank dans notre édition spéciale
ce témoignage également du couple qui
aida la famille d'anne frank à se cacher
des centaines de milliers de
manifestants en europe contre le risque
nucléaire un an après l annonce de la
catastrophe de la centrale de tchernobyl
en urss
jean marie le pen est officiellement
candidat à la présidence de la
république il a la profonde conviction
que la patrie est en grand danger
sport cette deuxième avec gérard holtz
et la qualification du racing pour la
finale du championnat de france de rugby
aujourd'hui dimanche 26 avril 1987
nouvelle journée de détention pour les
otages français au liban marcel fontaine
et marcel carton
jean paul kauffmann et jean louis
normandin d'antenne 2 n'ont toujours pas
été libérés
bonsoir avant cette édition spéciale qui
coïncide avec la journée nationale du
souvenir voyons l'actualité ce dimanche
et en toute immodestie permettez moi une
bonne nouvelle pour antenne de michel
drucker a décidé de continuer à apporter
l'exclusivité de sa collaboration à
antenne 2 champs elysées se poursuivra
avec des moyens accrus et la direction
d'antenne 2 se réjouit de la poursuite
de cette collaboration
un sondage publié demain porter les
poches confirme également que michel
drucker et champs elysées sont les plus
appréciées des téléspectateurs français
bonne semaine donc pour antenne 2 avec
la poursuite des collaborations de
bernard pivot et de michel drucker dans
toute l'europe et même dans certains
pays de l'est comme la tchécoslovaquie
les écologistes et les anti-nucléaires
ont manifesté pour commémorer la
catastrophe nucléaire de tchernobyl
philippe dumez 3000 manifestants au
moins à thionville simulant une mort
collective à la suite d'une catastrophe
nucléaire
c'était cet après midi où les
antinucléaires étaient venus dire non à
la centrale tout proche de cattenom sur
les pancartes non à 4 mobile pour
rappeler qu'il ya un an s'est produit le
plus grave accident nucléaire civil qui
a fait 30 morts et des centaines de
blessés
une manifestation calme et bon enfant où
de nombreux allemands luxembourgeois et
belges étaient aussi présents
encore un symbole à lâcher de ballons
comme pour simuler une importante fuite
radioactive dans l'atmosphère pourquoi
s'en prendre à cattenom parce que cette
centrale est située sur la moselle non
loin de la belgique de l'allemagne et
surtout du luxembourg 90% de ce pays
habitant hôpitaux industries se trouve
en effet à moins de 40km de ce danger
potentiel
cette centrale avec ses quatre réacteurs
de 13 100 mégawatts sera en effet quand
tout fonctionnera une des plus
puissantes d'europe mais sa conception
n'a rien à voir avec celle de tchernobyl
en fait on a manifesté un peu partout
comme ici en italie du nord
près d'une centrale nucléaire également
une chaîne humaine de 28 kilomètres de
long où les écologistes très
sensibilisés par la catastrophe de
tchernobyl
volt espérer un avenir sans nucléaire
un groupe de recherche américain public
citizen affirme que 3000 incident au
cours de l'année dernier ont été
recensés dans quatorze centrales
nucléaires des états unis greenpeace
publie un rapport et affirme qu'un
accident semblable à celui de tchernobyl
est parfaitement possible en grande
bretagne en france la question est
évidemment posé avec son auxiliaire sur
les conséquences humaines dossier
préparé par françois cornet une heure 23
minutes et 46 secondes
cette nuit là le réacteur de la tranche
4 de la centrale ukrainienne de
tchernobyl vient d'exploser à la suite
d'un essai mal préparée
entraînant la rupture de toutes les
tuyauteries de sortie de vapeur sous
l'effet de la pression
la lourde dalle de béton situé au dessus
du bâtiment réacteur s'est soulevée
libérant des fragments de combustible et
des blocs de grafite qui durant une
dizaine de jours vont former un nuage
radioactif qui ne connaîtra pas de
frontières la france elle relativement
épargnés par les retombées ne subira pas
plus d'effet selon les experts que par
la radioactivité naturelle mais
l'information du public français mal
conduite trop techniques insuffisantes
va déclencher une série de questions qui
un an après ce poste encore cet accident
le plus grave de l'ère nucléaire
entraînera-t-il une augmentation du
nombre des cancers
oui en union soviétique répondent les
spécialistes non ou peu probable
ailleurs les autres pays dans toutes les
autres régions d'europe
l'excès de cancer n'est qu'hypothétique
on ne le verra certainement pas il est
même très probable qu'en france il n'y
aura aucun cancer du retombées de
tchernobyl
la raison en est très simple c'est que
lorsque l'on compare des populations
humaines recevant des doses
d'irradiation naturelle très différentes
on est incapable d'observer des effets
de cancer chez les plus irradiés
tchernobyl ces quelques jours
d'irradiation naturelle en plus donc une
dose tellement faible en france les
effets à long terme seront quasiment nul
reste maintenant devant ces images une
autre question un accident de type
tchernobyl
peut-il se produire en france où la
sécurité des réacteurs grâce à leur
enceinte de protection et de confinement
est mieux assurée gravissime accident
qui pourrait se produire et que nous
n'avons jamais nié qu'il puisse se
produire est une fusion du coeur de type
tes amis voire plus importante
mais pour lesquels les dispositions sont
telles que la menace vers le public est
vraiment extrêmement minimiser en est en
tout cas n'a aucune commune mesure avec
ce qu'étaient les caractéristiques de
tchernobyl tchernobyl 1 aujourd'hui est
une certitude
cet accident marquera longtemps
l'histoire du nucléaire civil à la
trinité sur mer dans le morbihan jean
marie le pen président du front national
a annoncé officiellement sa candidature
à la présidence de la république grave
décision selon monsieur le pen qui a la
profonde conviction que la patrie est en
grand danger
reportage henry elie marcel martin
devant la maison natale de jean marie le
pen des partisans des amis enfin des
électeurs du morbihan mais également
d'autres départements se sont
rassemblées ce quelques drapeaux et
bannières tricolore patientant avant
l'arrivée l annonce officielle du
président du front national
aucune surprise n'est en fait
véritablement attendu les en revanche
c'est une déclaration solennelle à
laquelle on assiste
un véritable coup d'envoi d'une très
longue campagne électorale
d'ores et déjà planifiée et organisée un
an juste avant l'échéance du 24 avril 88
j'ai pris la grave décision d'être l'an
prochain candidat à la présidence de la
république
homme de foi le croiser avec passion que
le destin n'est pas inéluctable et qu'il
y as pour la france un avenir d'espoir
on peut que chacune et chacun d'entre
vous français en face son affaire car
c'est son affaire et dont nous j'en suis
sûr dieu nous aidera
en attendant que son voeu soit exaucé le
président du front national multiplient
meetings et manifestations à travers la
france comme ici à la trinité sur mer où
il vient d'entamer un véritable marathon
électoral dont ils se veulent arbitres
et bien que cet acte politique
paraissent aujourd'hui quelque peu
prématuré un an avant l'échéance
présidentielle jean-marie le pen ne
craint pas semble-t-il de s'essouffler
d'ici là réaction à cette candidature
une déclaration de matamore dérisoire
dit andré rossinot le radical pour qui
roule monsieur le pen questionne jacques
toubon du rpr et dominique strauss kahn
du parti socialiste constate la droite
est extrêmement divisé vis-à-vis de la
campagne la candidature le pen dans les
autres déclarations politiques de ce
dimanche elle concerne les remous au
sein de l'udf il convient de noter celle
de philippe de villiers secrétaire
d'état à la culture interrogé dans le
magazine le point à paraître demain
on peut être dans la bande à léo et dans
le banc de raymond barre fils de vivier
soutiendra raymond barre avec
détermination
s'il est candidat à l'élection
présidentielle et puis ce soir au club
de la presse en europe numéro un jean
claude gaudin président du groupe udf
estimait que si le parti républicain
dont il est membre lui-même décidé de
présenter à tout prix la candidature de
son secrétaire général françois léotard
à l'élection présidentielle eh bien il
ferait le choix de l'aventuré celui de
la division les le premier ministre
jacques chirac qui était aujourd'hui en
grande bretagne dans la résidence de
campagne de son homologue britannique
madame thatcher les entretiens ont porté
essentiellement sur les questions de
désarmement à londres le commentaire de
notre correspondant alain cances cet
après midi au checkers la résidence de
week end et premier ministre britannique
madame thatcher et monsieur jacques
chirac ont tellement tout parler des
problèmes du désarmement nucléaire en
europe et notamment des propositions
soviétique de suppression des sanitaires
ont rien apporté
les fn un projet qui intéresse les
américains mais qui par bien des côtés
inquiète les européens tout
particulièrement la france et la grande
bretagne
je ne veux pas préjuger de ce qui sera
la décision finale je dis simplement que
l'on ne peut pas s'engager dans un
processus qui consisterait à découper en
tranches
les négociations sur l'armement
nucléaire jusqu à l'armement
je dirais que nous appelons nous
tactique si vous voulez c'est à dire à
très courte portée qui n'est pas encore
concerné 1 ce qui serait une orientation
qui pourrait conduire à une sorte de
dénucléarisation
en tous les cas s'agissant des armes
américaines de l'europe ne les centres
en europe que les systèmes centraux
français britannique et ce qui compte
tenu par ailleurs de l'existence du
système central soviétique et du profond
déséquilibre qui existe entre les forces
conventionnelles et chimiques du pacte
de varsovie par rapport à aux forces
occidentales conduire naturellement à
une beaucoup plus grande vulnérabilité
de l'europe
dans quelques semaines les pays
européens vont devoir faire connaître
leurs alliés américains leur poser sur
cette question des armes nucléaires à
moyenne portée
d'ici là français et britanniques qui
ont fui cette question des attitudes
frais similaires ont essayé de
convaincre les autres pays européens de
parler d'une seule voix les six
personnes interpellées par la dst d'un
cadre de l' enquête sur les attentats de
mars et septembre 86 à paris ont été
inculpés ce matin mais ni les identités
ni les chefs d'inculpation ont été
rendus publics
l'arrestation en guadeloupe de plusieurs
militants indépendantistes de l'ariège
c'est l'alliance révolutionnaire
caraïbes des explosifs et des armes ont
été découverts dans un appartement à
pointe-à-pitre
en espagne les cérémonies du 50e
anniversaire du bombardement de guernica
n'ont pas été seulement l'occasion d'un
recueillement de manifestations de
souvenirs mais aussi d'affrontements un
attentat en effet été commis dans la
nuit contre le siège du parti socialiste
puis des militants nationalistes
bath ont échangé des coups avec le
service d'ordre du parti au pouvoir dans
la région
l'actuel président du gouvernement
basque a cependant lancé un appel à la
paix et à la réconciliation
l'édition spéciale que la rédaction
d'antenne 2 vous propose ce soir
coïncide avec une journée de souvenir la
journée nationale de la déportation
elles étaient célébrées ce matin aux
invalides au mont valérien et puis ce
soir à l'arc de triomphe de l'étoile sur
les champs-elysées à paris
en souvenir de tous les déportés de la
deuxième guerre mondiale le pape jean
paul ii a prononcé également hier soir
la télévision ouest allemande un sermon
dans lequel il a longuement évoqué les
camps de la mort nazis première partie
de cette édition spéciale un document un
document tourné en 1942 à amsterdam
un caméraman juifs amateurs harry schwab
a filmé la vie quotidienne de 14 juifs
qui y vécurent dans un petit appartement
dessous d'un cabaret et intitulé
l'alcazar ce film mais vient d'être
retrouvé en voici un montage
je dirais que c'est un peu l'équivalent
en images du journal d'anne frank avec
ces instants banal et puisque l'on
imagine de beaucoup plus terrifiant
amsterdam étaient 42 l'occupation
allemande dure déjà depuis plus de deux
ans
à première vue la vie dans la capitale
semble redevenue normale
mais ces images sont trompeuses
amsterdam est la première ville de
l'europe occupée ou la déportation des
juifs a été soigneusement préparé il est
clair qu'il existe deux catégories de
personnes amsterdam celles qui sont
considérées comme des aryens des blancs
de pure race et les autres hommes femmes
et enfants avec gilles pour juifs sur
leurs papiers d'identité et une étoile
jaune sur leur manteau tous sont à la
merci des nazis et leurs sauvegardes ne
tient qu'à une aide occasionnels et au
courage de quelques-uns à droite de la
place rend brand le centre de vie
nocturne d'amsterdam se trouve à
musicaux l'alcazar très exactement au 5
de la place torbeck
le fait que quatorze juifs parviennent à
se cacher ici n'est pas exceptionnel
mais ce qui l'est c'est que leur vie
secrète va être filmé ce film est
probablement le seul tourner dans ces
conditions c'est du 16 mm noir et blanc
bien évidemment mais il débute par
l'arrivée des juifs dans l'appartement
de dirt brigitte juste au dessus de
l'alcazar le voici dire accueillant les
premiers arrivants il ne se doute pas
encore qu'ils vont demeurer ici pendant
onze mois
onze mois de réclusion imaginer qu'anne
frank se soit servi d'une caméra plutôt
que d'un crayon c'est ce qu'elle nous
montrerait des petits riens des choses
qui font la vie des choses qui font
risquer la mort à ceux qui ont eu le
courage de ne pas plier devant les
persécuteurs ils vont se retrouver à 14
14 dont arish lab
le producteur de ce film harish vab s'en
souvient 45 ans plus tard
je sentais que toutes ces personnes
vivaient sous une tension extrême
renforcé par les menaces et les
événements extérieurs que la radio nous
apprenait les juifs comme d'autres
d'ailleurs été arrachés à leurs maisons
nous vivions une gaieté sur fait comme
des marionnettes
les gens pleuraient mais devait jouer en
même temps
la comédie c'était notre tragédie
obligés de nous cacher une situation
dramatique qu'on a de la peine à décrire
comme mode la caméra enregistre tous les
instants des longues journées
préparation des repas rationner par les
tickets d'alimentation petites scènes de
tous les jours où chacun joue son rôle
jour après jour
sous l'oeil complice de l'objectif les
reclus apprennent les première défaite
des armées allemandes
nous avons conservé ces images celles
pendant lesquels ils ont confirmation de
la victoire des armées soviétiques à
stalingrad
mais amsterdam la chasse à l'homme
s'intensifie pas seulement la chasse aux
juifs tous les hommes entre 18 et 35 ans
sont requis pour le travail obligatoire
en allemagne ou pour l'allemagne ces
mauvaises nouvelles comme les bonnes
vont parvenir jusqu à l'alcazar
ainsi ce jour-là de riches rich annonce
à arish vab l'arrestation de son frère
beaucoup de juifs font leurs bagages
prêt pour la déportation dire que les
chances d'y échapper sont minces
de plus tous savent désormais que les
allemands ne les emmène pas chez eux
pour travailler mais pour les exterminer
les plus âgés ceux qui savent le test
aux enfants et font semblant de
l'ignorer se forçant à rire parfois
exercice d' alerte à l'alcazar pour la
caméra mais en grandeur réelle avec le
risque réel que dans la minute
dans une heure un jour ce ne soit plus
un exercice d'ailleurs dans quelques
jours ce ne sera plus un exercice
le subterfuge comme l'exercice d'alert
ne seront d'aucun secours un jour de mai
les allemands et leurs miliciens
hollandais met le paquet les portes sept
sous leurs épaules et inéluctablement un
après midi
ilsont à celle de l'alcazar
brusquement on entendit la sonnette elle
retentit plusieurs fois aussitôt nous
passâmes tous à l'action et taxis hélas
nous n'avons pu éviter l'arrestation de
nos dix camarades
les quatre autres n'ont pas réussi à
s'enfuir
deux hommes se dissimule derrière
l'armoire le plus jeune derrière le lit
et une femme sous les escaliers
à 4 heures de l'après midi en sont
revenus une seconde fois
heureusement ma femme n'est pas nerveux
et pendant que l'ennemi sonné en bas
elle a ménagé la cachette sous
l'escalier il y avait de la place pour
deux
on s'y étant passé à quatre pendant une
heure une heure et demie peut-être il
n'y avait pratiquement plus d'air à
l'intérieur mais ma femme réussit tout
de même à rabattre une planche soumettre
une poubelle devant et à la recouvrir
d'un rideau sur trois
pour se souvenir de ce temps-là harry
cheval n'a pas besoin du film la
découverte des cachettes les
arrestations le sortirons jamais de sa
mémoire
deux des fugitifs ne reviendront pas du
camp de concentration de bergen-belsen
deux autres se suicideront les dix
autres survivront dont dark et marie les
patrons de l'alcazar
impressionnant documents inédits tournés
donc en 1942 1943 par ari shvat 7 et à
amsterdam et à cette même époque me
glisser son mari et des la famille frank
se cachait dans leur maison d'amsterdam
iblis retrouva le journal de la petite
juive après sa déportation et sa mort au
camp de bergen belsen
régis a décidé de raconter anne frank
dans ce livre ce livre publié aux
éditions calmann lévy et le livre
commence ainsi je vais me permettre de
vous faire une lecture je n'ai rien
d'héroïque je ne suis que le maillon
final de la longue très longue chaîne de
braves hollandais qui ont fait ce que
j'ai fait ou plus beaucoup plus en cette
période sombre terrible a jamais
présente dans le coeur de ceux d'entre
nous qui en furent les témoins il n'est
pas un jour où je ne songe à ce qui s'y
passe à ce matin pour antenne 2
françoise champel jean-françois hochmann
était à amsterdam
il est à peine 10 heures à amsterdam ce
matin et déjà des dizaines de touristes
attendent l'ouverture des portes de la
maison d'anne frank
six cent mille visiteurs chaque année un
hommage en forme de recueillement on
vient ici pour voir la cachette que huit
personnes ont occupé pendant près de
deux ans une histoire traduite en 55
langues le journal d'anne frank
les pensées d'une jeune fille morte en
1945 à l'âge de 16 ans déportation à
bergen belsen
aujourd'hui après 40 ans de silence me
paie son mari raconte ils ont caché anne
frank et les siens jusqu'au jour où la
gestapo est venu les chercher le 4 août
1944 le 4 août un jour vécu tous les
jours nous ce jour est le plus difficile
de l'année
quand nous nous levons nous évitons de
regarder la sphère privée
et puis on se parle le moins possible
parce que ce jour-là nous savons
exactement
heure par heure ce qui s'est passé
depuis vers 5h ses films on est plus
calme et la journée que se poursuivre
normalement
fun lorsque le journal a été publié je
n'ai pas pu le lire je n'y arrivais pas
c'était trop et lisa la deuxième édition
otto frank le père d'anne m'a persuadé
de le faire
j'ai dit d'accord mais je ne le lirai
que quand je serai seul alors je les lui
ai je reconnais honnêtement que j'ai été
soulagé il s'en dégager une telle
chaleur conséquent fait ce serait bien
pire
en fait ce qui était bien c'est que je
me suis retrouvé parmi eux mêmes
pendant des années j'ai ressorti de la
haine mais j'en suis arrivé à la
conclusion que la haine ne mène à rien n
est pas finie elle n'a pas de but du
string d'eau en fait elle se retourne
contre eux jouer mais il est important
que l'on n'oublie pas ce qui s'est passé
je n'ai pas pu empêcher cette trajet la
déportation de toute une famille
elle doit rester un symbole nous n'avons
pas forcé notre petite pierre
le retour est fixé dans la mémoire des
hommes
nous ne sommes pas des ronds nous avons
cela fait notre devoir est d'aider
personnes qui en avaient besoin
rien de plus c'était bien sûr un travail
dangereux on le faisait on le faisait
pas nous n'avions pas le choix nous
l'avons fait un point c'est tout
moi je fais cette édition spéciale
dirais simplement qu'il faut relier au
journal d'anne frank c'est dans
l'édition de poche tout simplement et
puis ce livre me glisse elle s'appelait
anne frank 7 aux éditions calmann lévy
c'est l'histoire de la femme qui aida la
famille frank à se cacher 1942 1943
sports gérard on va commencer par une
belle surprise pour le racing ne se
retrouvent combien d'années après en
finale le champion de france 28 ans 1
oui en effet demi finales du championnat
de france et pour la finale c'est un
phénomène étonnant le sud ouest est hors
jeu
laquerre française du rugby en effet a
été éliminé toulon hyères aujourd'hui
toulouse avec en particulier cet essai
du racing marqué par guillard après un
démarrage de mesnel relayé par blanc à
la dernière minute
ensuite les toulousains par une avec une
pénalité de dupuy vont tenter de réduire
le score voilà mais ça passe à gauche
c'était la dernière possibilité pour le
toulouse d'égaliser
le racing va gagner cette demi finale 10
points à 9 joie extraordinaire pour les
bleu et blanc qui tout au long de la
saison ont montré qu'il savait jouer au
rugby et qu'ils avaient en plus le sens
de la fête et de l'humour 28 ans après
donc le racing en finale samedi prochain
en direct sur antenne 2 contre toulon ce
sera à 20h30 au parc des princes est
content oui avec tafari à clé et un
gérald martinez qui a battu ses anciens
coéquipiers ont face aux cyclistes sur
est le touriste paille troisième étape
aujourd'hui contre la montre victoire de
l'irlandais sean kelly il a fait coup
double parce qu'en plus il endosse le
maillot amarillo qui comme chacun sait
est le maillot jaune c'est grave
merci beaucoup je vous en prie on va
parler d'une ceni ce fut vous m'avez dit
une drôle de semaine
oui une semaine en forme de grand
échiquier avec échec et mat échec au
pluriel car pour beaucoup de stars ils
ne sont pas encore habitués à la terre
battue becker nos icebergs ont été
battus et puis matmat pour mats wilander
il est au fond là-bas et il a gagné cet
après midi en battant
l américain jimmy arias en quatre sets
alors bien la partie résumé la voix si
je lis tu tues lift il lifte nous
listons pays lift et puis jimmy arias
lasserre la côte et finalement il perdra
le match jimmy arias en quatre sets donc
4 6 7 5 6 1 6 3 nous allons voir
maintenant la balle de match
il s'agit encore de lift voilà arias au
filet l'un des meilleurs coups droits du
monde d'un des élèves de nick
bollettieri l'américain gros coup droit
donc ce soir
victoire de mats wilander dans ce
tournoi de monte-carlo 1987 est à
prendre avec la police était le football
vous rappeler que bordeaux donc a battu
monaco un match comptant pour la coupe
de france 8e de finale match aller 2 à 0
hier soir tours bordeaux avec un
extraordinaire but josé touré coupe de
france + coupes d'europe pour bordeaux
c'est bonjour l'infirmerie pour
battiston tigana et ferrari ils sont
blessés
oui ils sont forfait donc pour france
islande qui a lieu mercredi prochain
olivier rey timbale vièvre là où sont
les rayons c'est ça l'équipe de france
olivier vous êtes avec nous henri michel
joe torre et carmelo buttino a fêté sa
première sélection en principe mercredi
prochain alors trois absents de marque
battiston quillanais et jean marc
ferreri qui est reparti tout à l'heure
donc qui vous appeler pour ceux pour les
remplacer en placement de 7 ans garçons
j'ai appelé jean françois domergue
fabrice poullain dominique bijotat alors
c'est un match important pour l'équipe
de france puisque l'équipe de france
reste sur trois résultats où elle n'a
pas marqué de but et un match qui peut
relancer l'équipe de france dans le
championnat d'europe des nations
je dirais même 80 cents en cas de but et
c'est vrai comme on a envie de renouer
avec la victoire et puis nous paraît
important aussi essentiel de continuer à
croire à une qualification même si notre
situation compromise mais s'il reste une
chance nous la jouerons à fond et ça
commence à partir de mercredi
alors carmelo missiles c'est le nouveau
joueur de cette équipe de france
l'attaquant de metz alors tout surpris
de se retrouver ici en équipe de france
oui j'étais surpris d'avoir été retenu
dans le 16 mai pour moi c'est un peu une
simple nouvelle aventure pour moi de
figurer dans leurs selles de l'équipe de
france vous espérer jouer d'entrée ce
match je ne sais pas pour l'instant on
verra bien il annoncera l'équipe mardi
josé touré en revanche c'est le grand
retour vous n'avez pas joué avec
l'équipe de france depuis plus d'un an
le dernier match était contre la
yougoslavie un match qualificatif pour
la coupe du monde au mexique alors que
tout ça c'est de revenir oui c'est
toujours très plaisir bien entendu et je
crois que c'était une longue attente et
j'ai su être patient pour retrouver à
peu près tous les moyens et si je suis
sélectionné c'est peut-être parce que je
le méritais au donc c'est une sorte de
récompense et j'en suis très fier c'est
également la fin d'une longue marche ans
je jouais si vous voulez vous appelez ça
une malchance j'en sais rien pour moi ça
fut une expérience pour
pour ma vie donc je suis en retirer je
dirais pas quintessence mais des choses
qui étaient positives donc pour moi
c'est un nid un retour ni un renouveau
c'est une continuation
henri michel c'est également un match
pour l'équipe de france une occasion de
redorer son blason et puis d'offrir un
très beau spectacle au public parisien
ouvert en tous les cas je l'espère je le
souhaite ardemment après un début de
saison où les résultats n'ont pas été
bons notre manière n'a pas été très
bonne
nous avons eu une bonne réaction saine
un gardien qui a été diversement
commentée alors j'espère que à travers
semences comme tristan n'ont pu se
retrouver ce qui a fait toute la qualité
des couleurs français de l'équipe de
france qui n'a permis notre résultat
une dernière question est ce que lui si
chez a fêté déjà ça sa sélection est ce
qu il a offert le champagne mais je
crois qu'il est venu sans argent parce
qu'il a oublié mais ça ne saurait tarder
très bien merci messieurs très bonne
chanson sera auprès de vous pour se
battre sur france islande on voit
peut-être d'autres vues et d'autres
matchs d'hier légende les josé n'est pas
sourd vous écouter il avait mis un petit
district dans l'oreille et coquet alors
oui pour compléter la séquence football
regardez bien messieurs vous qui est en
stage à val bièvre l'aller but venu
d'ailleurs sélectionné par francis
maroteaux il y en a de superbes il ya
aussi de superbes arrêts des gardiens
début étrangers en allemagne le bayern
en rouge va bien malgré ce premier but
de l'ipl poupe bochum paradoxe nine
bremer pour le bayern égalise sur coup
franc son entraîneur udo lattek heureux
lui accorde la vie sauve d'autant que
deux minutes plus tard
lothar mathaus inscrit le but de la
victoire pour le bayern finaliste de la
coupe d'europe en tête de son
championnat
l'autre finaliste portant maillots rayés
l'a également emporté 2 1 contre
boavista premier but filtré
deuxième mi-temps et deuxième but de
porto [ __ ] et de la tête par enti sur
penalty réduit la marque italie à naples
le napoli en bleu face au milan ac gagne
également de 1,7 un abonnement premier
but centre de maradona tête et but
carnet vanille et puis le génie de diego
maradona regarder dire d'istres amène le
score final à 2 1
enfin brésil en jaune uruguay en version
originale
égalisation de l'uruguay talonnade
frappe pied gauche pour le tiercé
d'aujourd'hui qui marquait les 130 ans
de l'hippodrome de longchamp voici le
résultat 6 15 et 12 et les rapports de
ce tiercé si vous voulez bien tes voir
avec cette arrivée sur l'hippodrome de
longchamp donc 6 15 12 dans l'or ça vous
donne 5340 de francs 50 et dans un ordre
différent 1068 francs 50 pour cinq ans
l'anniversaire a l'onction et pour la
météo vous nous promettez quoi en dire
autant
elle revient c'est vrai que nous vivons
un printemps estival là après une
dégradation de quelques jours le beau
temps revient c'est bien c'est agréable
mais cela risque de nous poser des
problèmes de sécheresse assez rapidement
alors pourquoi il revient
eh bien nous allons garder l'image sa
télé tout simplement parce que ces
nuages qui ont affecté la moitié nord
aujourd'hui vont mourir sur place
alors demain après une matinée nuageuse
l'après midi sera très ensoleillé vous
allez voir la carte partout du nord au
sud de l'ouest a lâché n'ai rien à vous
montrer le soutenait du soleil les
températures avec ce soleil et bien elle
remonte évidemment il nous irons dans
l'après-midi de 18 à 22 degrés sur la
moitié nord et de 20 à 25 degrés sur la
moitié sud avec un petit 26 semaines sur
biarritz demain ce sera le lundi 27
avril quatre minutes de ses rayons plus
célèbres à 6h40 se couchera 20h58 ce
sera la fête des zips merci beaucoup ce
soir c'est à 23h casque vous retrouverez
claude pour diane et journal de la
rédaction d'antenne 2 puis demain matin
télématin à partir de 6h45 trois jours
de 7 heures c'était
huit heures avec roger zabel et puis
paul nahon recevra pour les 4 vérités
ibrahim source
à demain 20h bonsoir merci